good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight happy thursday
so why are the democrats so angry we've
asked that question a number of times
it doesn't seem to make any sense truly
in november the democratic party won
everything full control of the federal
government they seized for years while
they were out of power that made sense
but winning seemed to enrage them even
more
did you watch democrats on television
today at the impeachment hearings
they are crazy person mad florid-faced
irrational yelling and making threats it
is bizarre
you'd think they get to work fixing the
country they inherited they promised to
do that
instead they said about breaking things
and hurting people
what is going on here well maybe it's
intrinsic
there's a certain sort of low character
person who becomes more vicious
in victory power makes them mean
the ottomans destroyed the cities they
captured there was never a good reason
to do this to kill people who had
already been
captured and who had surrendered the
ottomans did it because they enjoyed it
adam schiff and nancy pelosi have a
little bit of that in them it looks like
imagine being adam schiff's landscaper
or nancy pelosi's housekeeper or anyone
at their command
imagine how they treat the staff with no
restaurant how would they tip
you know the answer they're the kind of
people who flatter the boss and scream
at the interns
they suck up and they spit down jeff
bezos is a god to them
you mean nothing so naturally the
democratic party is constructing a world
designed to serve jeff bezos you're an
afterthought in that world
if you get in the way they will punish
you they already are punishing you
your right to say and think what you
want to read and watch what you want
threatens them above all why because if
you have
access to information you can form your
own judgments judgments that are
independent
of theirs a free internet is their enemy
the moment they took power they began a
kind of counter reformation against the
free internet
they started the most sweeping mass
censorship campaign in the history of
this country
and it's accelerating even now yesterday
for example google
pulled a pro-life news site off of
youtube why'd they do that
simple google supports abortion a lot of
big corporations do
children distract the labor force if
you're raising your family you are not
serving shareholders
google doesn't want to debate on those
subjects so they just shut the debate
down
hundreds of thousands of subscribers to
lifesite news will no longer be watching
videos that question
abortion because they're not allowed to
then today
twitter shut down james o'keefe's
project veritas twitter feed
there was no justifiable reason to do
this but no one in the media asked
questions about it or appeared to
consider it a problem
quote project veritas has been known
politico announced gravely
to spread misinformation now the person
who wrote that sentence a child reporter
called anna whose twitter handled bragg
she went to cornell
didn't even bother to explain what that
so-called misinformation
was but you know what it was project
veritas had criticized the people in
charge
that's enough now anna didn't question
that standard she seemed pleased to play
a role in silencing grown-up reporters
she thinks that's her job good work anna
you work at politico now you get to be
america's room monitor and tell the rest
of us what to say
how empowering all the child reporters
feel that way that's why they're in
favor of it
so project veritas is off twitter
tonight but the red guards still aren't
satisfied
they will not rest until there is not a
single human being remaining in
all american media who questions any of
the platitudes that anna and her friends
memorized at cornell in lieu of an
actual education diversity is our
strength
trans rights are human rights abortion
is health care
they don't think about it they just
accept whatever the central committee
decides is the slogan of the day
and anyone who mocks or disagrees with
those slogans is silenced
in the name of diversity we must have
uniformity
well of all the impediments to achieving
this goal of uniformity those would
include centuries of
tradition the first amendment to the
constitution the fact this was a free
country
of all of those it's this channel fox
news
that is the most significant hurdle to
getting everyone to sing from the same
song sheet
fox is the last big organization in the
american news media
that differs in even the smallest ways
from the other big news organizations
the only one that's it
just us at this point there's everyone
else in the media standing in crisp
formation in their starched matching
uniforms in their little caps
patiently awaiting orders from the
billionaire class
and then there's fox news off by itself
occasionally saying things that are
slightly different from everyone else
on fox there are still journalists who
are willing to think for themselves
sometimes and brave enough to say so out
loud
it seems like that's what journalism
should be but in 2021 it's a very rare
thing
and the oligarchs hate it jeff bezos for
one has had enough of it
bezos has sent forth his personal
scribes from the washington post
to make us go away to end fox news
on command they've written a number of
columns suggesting that fox news must be
silenced
they've gone on television to demand
that fox news is silenced
here's one of jeff bezos's employees
there are other options including the
fact that cable operators
like comcast and charter which send fox
out to
hundreds of millions of people they can
demand some accountability in the way
that
facebook and twitter have done and
there's also i think the possibility of
reviving
the fairness doctrine there are a lot of
ways to silence fox news he has
explained on television and
in columns but he doesn't call it
silencing fox news he says we must
demand some accountability
authorized questions no more criticizing
jeff bezos
and he's not the only one saying it in
the last 30 days
a single columnist at the new york times
called nick kristoff
has written three separate columns
demanding that someone please
yank this news channel off the air
immediately
just yesterday kristoff suggested that
this show the one you're watching
was somehow guilty of terrorism of
violence something that we've been
opposed consistently
for four years how are we guilty of that
and why
well because ashley babbitt the unarmed
protester shot to death at the capitol
on january 6th
apparently watch this show from time to
time at 8pm
now keep in mind that ashley babbitt is
dead she paid quite a price for trying
to enter the speaker's lobby without
permission
and no one mourned her what kind of
country is it by the way
and we're saying this as a show that was
against what they did on january 6 from
the second they did it
but what kind of country is it where
nobody says well wait that's kind of sad
they shot an unarmed woman is that
really a death penalty offense
how hard-hearted are we that no one can
even acknowledge
that sad which it is what kind of
country is it where
a republican member of congress from
oklahoma applauded
her death immediately nick kristoff
is applauding it but for nick kristof
her death is not enough
now we need to ban any television shows
that ashley babbitt may have watched
we're not even going to rebut that it's
not even worth your time
to hear us explain why that is
irrational
it's self-evidently irrational paul pott
reads the new york times therefore we
need to close the paper down
john wayne gacy liked a nick kristoff
column therefore nick kristoff is
guilty of mass murder he's a serial
killer too
that's what nick kristoff is saying we
would never say something like that
ever it's too stupid but nothing is too
stupid
for nick kristof or the new york times
what kristoff lacks
in reason he makes up for with vehemence
nick kristoff
in the end cannot stand the idea that
someone
somewhere might be publicly disagreeing
with him so he's calling for forcible
censorship
what would be nice is if he just said it
out loud yeah i'm calling for censorship
be a man about it and admit what you're
doing but of course you'll never do that
these are not men
these are craven servants of the
democratic party they are
feline not canine all of their
aggression
is passive aggression watch another
slope shoulder tool of the oligarchy
feign outrage
that we have called censorship what it
is censorship oh but it's not censorship
he whines
it's harm reduction and tucker carlson
is telling viewers that
this network cnn is trying to force fox
news
off the air which is patently false
but while some cry cancel culture let me
suggest a different way to think about
this
a harm reduction model but reducing a
liar's reach
is not the same as censoring freedom of
speech freedom of speech is different
than freedom of
reach oh let me suggest a different
model
the harm reduction model notice the
seductively
imprecise language of personal therapy
we're all aoc now it's all about us
it's not a fascist crackdown on free
speech by ruthless and
power mad billionaires no not at all
it's just harm reduction
like methadone or nicorette it's a way
to get better
when they come for you they will talk
like social workers
guaranteed